I sat down to write this essay was the
first thing I ever wrote that wasn't
preschool to make sense to myself of why
it was so hard for women to say what
they felt or thought and be heard
without having it distorted and come
back to them in some way that just
didn't even sound like what they were
trying to say.
And also how come I hadn't seen the
absence of women from the psychology I
was teaching,
you know,
so I thought maybe my mother would read
this book or people who worked on the
same floor.
I worked on it at Harvard.
It never occurred to me,
but I wrote this paper and it started to
circulate like almost as a kind of
underground thing.
So it was.
That was a huge discovery for me.
Just really huge.
I didn't expect it.
Harvard press,
when they publish the book,
they publish 3000 copies.
Nobody expected.
It's had a huge impact.
It's had a huge.
I mean,
I'll tell you would like one good
example,
which is women used to be seen as
unintelligent because we were set to be
emotional.
You know,
men were rational and women were
emotional.
Well,
you know,
honestly,
if you think about,
that's ridiculous because men have
feelings and women thing.
So now we have this I phrase emotional
intelligence and it's a big vaunted
phrase because it's,
you know,
corporations are supposed to incorporate
it and people forget that.
Where that came from was this word
questioning this division between
emotional women and intelligent humans
and saying,
when you joined these qualities,
which had been seen as women's qualities
with human qualities there,
those are all human quality.
So we have emotional intelligence and
relational self and most recently the
feeling brain.
And that means that the whole paradigm.